Steph obviously the last playoff one you
guys had you scored 50 and it was a big
deal but just the uh the TCC in you like
these type of wins where it's up and
down the lineup you know all these
people contributing you only take 12
shots do you get a special satisfaction
out of that
I do but I like to shoot too
so just again just finding ways to be
impactful and be aggressive
and whatever's working sticking with
that until until you have to do
something different so
we're capable of playing a lot of
different ways I'm capable of playing a
lot of different ways
you know as long as we're just creating
open shots no matter who's taking them
and
obviously tonight I didn't have a lot of
open ones for a reason and
uh make the right make the right
decision the ball finds the right person
and uh good things happen
see Angelo Russell
this fires there Curry throws it ahead
here's to Michael Green inside lays it
up I mean green drops and courage is a
smaller Defender
Curry finds Draymond Green clear pass
with a basket no one coming to help in
an easy bucket
[Applause]
he was only six of 20 from three so far
in the playoffs Thompson the soft touch
gets the bounce he's running around on
and off the ball so just our continuous
multiple efforts and keeping our Pursuit
hi Lisa uh zwerny Banks it on one and
Gabriel getting his first minutes
rebounds all even so far
he gets free whips a pass Steven chenzo
that's a three and that's a no
hesitation use up Jeff
[Applause]
stolen by Curry
on the drive now pulls back finds Clay
Thompson his three-pointers
made a couple
absolutely outstanding unselfish plays
here probing in transition fundamentally
dropped it off the cut he's seven of ten
from the field including a couple of
threes
Curry finding Looney Looney with the
left hand that's the seventh assist for
Steph Curry
[Music]
[Applause]
Curry searching gorgeous feed your
Michael Green throws it down he got hit
in the head too to Michael Green jumper
and then once again
foreign
points
Curry fakes the pass now gets it to
Michael green and
it's up the foul
oh yeah
they'll say he was fumbling it but all I
know is sometimes that's who I am Mike
oh my goodness well he's having a great
game too
Draymond Green the pass another gorgeous
speed Curry and Draymond Green connect
once again
Rooney's played 12 minutes
inside moody moody goes in and throws it
down
Riker's just standing there that time
Harry with his 12th assist he spotted
him
and nobody stopped Moody one 10-80 as we
head to the fourth
[Applause]